a few hours before we're check-in was
expected to be published
we found an error in the code we don't
normally do things in 15 weeks it's not
something that we normally do you'd be
surprised how few people were able to
check in through our digital platform
mr. story about an airline that's been
able to use technology to showcase his
warmth and hospitality to the world
we're in a very competitive environment
customers visit dozens of travel
websites before making their transaction
what we need is a digital environment
that shows us for what we are a 5-star
airline with incredible experience we
needed a fresh approach to development
is quite complex business transformation
we align our discussions whether they
had along the hybrid cloud strategy this
project had eight different streams
internally running within the piece of
work and therefore eight different
integrations twelve different ecosystems
under the hood that have to be
integrated we had daily stand-ups we
basically followed the garage
methodology embraced the concept of
prata site to include a box of a modular
agile delivery
[Music]
we were able to do a quick proof of
concept in two weeks less than two weeks
which really demonstrated to them the
power of the IBM cloud platform
microservices space technology
architecture helped us to develop code
in a matter of few hours published a
code into an environment which is safe
and secure and put it out of the market
to bring in business volume
[Music]
when we were in the delivery phase there
was rapid increments in front of
customers tested with real people so at
the end of the day by the time the
project was over right it was like a big
family we reached a point where we could
complete each other sentences we had 16
releases immediately after go-live which
is unheard of an anti heart for a
completely new application that's the
beauty of having a cloud based on a
microservices based architecture this
was unheard of this is part breaking
really and now with this first part our
journey complete people believe in that
vision that strategy in their
architecture that we put together
[Music]
you